let's just show you these latest
pictures into Azov events as they unfold
a 15 minutes ago it's a different angle
so let's just listen in so you can see
here this is from the other side of the
building as the soldiers stormed that
entrance we only heard the bangs but
this is them actually going in some yes
this was I think this is probably the
back entrance that we were looking at
you can see there the flashes coming
from the muzzle flashes of the weapons
being used they are punching through but
it is a clearly locked and it's a very
serious exchange of fire and there you
see a hostage being whipped away in the
background being taken away there just
as the operators go into the building
but this is how events unfolded in the
past minute also as armed soldiers
stormed that building and brought events
the 16-hour hostage crisis to a close we
now know from New South Wales Police who
have said this hostage crisis is now
over five people being taken away on
stretchers with paramedics attending
them according to a local news channel
in Sydney to others was stretchered away
we know that when the soldiers went in
there were definitely hostages still in
there because we first found one of them
being brought out just a short time
later she was walking yes